I love my digital art,
but I want to take it with
me out into the real world.
Thankfully we can access
augmented reality on
our mobile devices.
We could use this tool
to simply cover the world.
Or we could use it
to further connect
us to thisworld.
We had a lot of artists
reaching out to us,
so we created tools
to allow them to
augment their work.
And very quickly, we
had a community
of artists covering the world
with their augmented art.
It was beautiful.
This is just the beginning.
You could leave a digital
artwork on the street corner
for your lover to find.
You could reinvent
your backyard
with ananimated
treasure hunt
for your kids and their friends.
The digital worlds we build
can be awonderful playground
for exploring identity,
for learning new skills,
for practicingcreativity
and bringing our
communities together.